اذا س نحاول ان نبحث في تفاصيل عمليه
الاغتيال والاستهداف التي تمت في ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه سنبدا بالترتيب الزمني منذ
بعد ظهر اليوم كانت العاصمه بيروت تشهد
تحليقا مكثفا للطائرات المقاتله
الاسرائيليه ولكن كانت تحلق على ارتفاعات
عاليه جدا تم رصد هذه ال هذه الطلعات
الجويه
من قبل الجيش اللبناني وافاد بها بان
الطائرات الاسرائيليه كانت تحلق على
ارتفاعات عاليه ليس فقط فوق مدينه بيروت
والمناطق المحيطه بها الطلعات الجويه
امتدت على مساحه لبنان تقريبا بحسب الجيش
اللبناني العمليه تمت في ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه التي تقع تقريبا في هذا المكان
هي الى جنوب العاصمه بيروت تتبع اداريا
لها وت تمتد من الساحل الجنوبي لمدينه
بيروت الى اولى مناطق شرق بيروت وهي
محافظه جبل لبنان الاستهداف تم في منطقه
المشرفيه وهي واحده من مناطق الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت هذه هي الضاحيه الجنوبيه
او غالبيه مناطق الضاحيه الجنوبيه
تقريبا
وفي مطار بيروت ياتي قريب جدا وعند حدود
الضاحيه تقريبا هي مكان واحد ممتد يجمع
بينهما خط سريع يمتد من العاصمه بيروت
ويصل الى جنوب لبنان المشرفيه هي واحده من
مناطق الضاحيه الجنوبيه ليست كبيره
المساحه تقريبا لا تتجاوز 2 م مربع بل
ربما اقل من ذلك ولكن اهميه هذه المنطقه
انها تقع ضمن منطقه حاره حريك هي واحده من
المناطق التي تقع داخل منطقه حاره حريك
وحاره حريك كما تسمى هي احد ابرز المعاقل
لحزب الله وايضا في
منطقه الضاحيه الجنوبيه في المشرفيه هي
منطقه مكتظه بالسكان والابنيه قريبه من
بعضها ولكن ايضا يمر بالقرب منها هذا الخط
الذي نراه هنا هذه هي الطريق الدوليه التي
تسمى طريق بيروت دمشق الدوليه ومن قلب
المشرفيه هنا هذا هو واحد من ابرز الشوارع
داخل الضاحيه الجنوبيه جده هادي نصر الله
في هذه المنطقه وقع الاستهداف وتحديدا في
هذا
المكان هذا هو مكان المبنى الذي تعرض
لاستهداف من قبل الطائرات المقاتله عند
وقوع العمليه بدايه كان هناك لغط حول
طبيعه الاستهداف ما اذا كان قد تم بطائره
مسيره اطلقت على الاقل صاروخين باتجاه
المبنى او كانت طائره مقاتله ليحسم الجدل
بان التنفيذ تم عبر طائره اطلقت عدد من
الصواريخ اصابت بعض طوابق المبنى و ادت
الى هذه النتيجه